[Music]
in town they tell the story of the marsh
girl
the one who grew up alone in the wild
but they never really knew me
like most stories
the facts don't weigh into it
i didn't know how to do life
[Music]
i was better off learning from the marsh
hello miss kyle i hear not my muscles
the marsh taught me how to survive
but it couldn't teach me everything
you can't live alone in the marsh
forever
watch me all right
it's dangerous to live out here alone
like this
i'm fine here's something else ain't you
miss katherine clark is charged with the
murder
of chase andrews
prosecution has announced it will seek
the death penalty
i'm going to get out of here
one way or the other
be careful y'all might have known some
out there i will not live in fear
there were no footprints fingerprints
nothing
someone destroyed evidence
i know you have a world of reasons to
hate these people i never hated them
they hated me
you want me to peg for my life
[Music]
it's a dangerous world in it i don't
know there is a dark side to nature
just inventive ways to endure
against all odds
knows
[Music]
you